[Musique]
quand je demande
c'est un han
les cinq ministres qui sont en campagne
dans les hauts de france monsieur dupont
moretti qui apprend à coller des
affiches jean castex tu joues au
contrôleur dans le train paris nice
[Musique]
cet honneur emmanuel macron qui fait des
opérations de communication at you tube
au fait quelqu'un qui dirige la france
aujourd'hui les présidents à 200 % du
temps et il verrait blague mais il fait
des blagues
heureusement et il parle aux jeunes mais
il ya beaucoup de fonds le président de
la république fait les influenceurs ce
serait bien qu'ils pensent aux étudiants
qui font la file pour manger à peu près
normalement
c'était un exercice de communication
politique un exercice qui finalement
masqué aussi dans le même moment par
exemple la plainte de gérald darmanin
contre en diffamation contre eux
devraient pouvoir et que on a cette
espèce de dualité tout le temps dans un
gouvernement où on met en avant quelques
chose qui fait écran de fumée sur
quelque chose d'autre le ministre de
l'intérieur annonce porter plainte
contre audrey pulvar pour diffamation la
tête de liste aux régionales en île de
france soutenue par le ps avait jugé je
cite la manifestation soutenue par
l'extrême droite à laquelle participe un
ministre de l'intérieur qui marche sur
l'assemblée nationale pour faire
pression sur les députés sur la
représentation nationale en train
d'examiner un texte de loi concernant la
justice c'est une image qui pour moi
était assez glissante j'ai pas un peu
raccourci comme présentation des choses
monsieur barthez vous posez la question
à laquelle je ne peux pas répondre
qu'elles élèvent au mes à non non la
justice est saisie
moi je me cache pas derrière mon petit
doigt mais je me cache derrière des
règles constitutionnelles
j'ai interdiction de dire je le regrette
d'ailleurs ce que je pense de tout ça
voilà juste dit que ces glaçons ben oui
c'est de la santé inquiétant et d'autres
l'ont dit donc je ne sais pas à quoi
courent après quoi court monsieur
darmanin eux alex après l'extrême droite
ça c'est sûr ancien un abus d'autorité
de
du ministre de l'intérieur moi je
voudrais qu'il saisisse la justice c'est
qu'il respecte la justice bien davantage
qui le fait actuellement
et là en l'occurrence les cette menace
en diffamation qu'il avait eue contre
moi aussi me semble être des coups de
force permanent
madame pulvar tient des propos
absolument scandaleux lamentable et le
fait en toute circonstance on l'avait vu
sur la sphère traoré il ya quelques mois
on le voit aujourd'hui contre la police
mais gérald darmanin en réalité ce fait
de la publicité à peu de frais lorsque
l'on dit que les policiers marcherait
sur les institutions de la république
alors qu'ils en sont les protecteurs et
qu'ils meurent parce qu'ils nous
protègent
je ne peux pas laisser même en campagne
électorale des gens tenir de tels propos
diffamants et mon travail de mise
intérieur c'est de protéger ce qui nous
protège rivieyran du sang sur les mains
et bien c'est un mange merde inconnu et
aucune raison de le suivre
alex auld mais bon mais je pense que
mange merde ça lui va bien qui a signé
au silence une candidate à une élection
ce que nous pouvons interpréter
autrement que comme une grossière
manoeuvre d'intimidation
nous avons donc décidé de porter plainte
comment quand on est un humoriste qui ne
fait plus rire personne on peut utiliser
sa sa notoriété pour dire d'aider des
conneries pareilles excusez moi mais
c'est atterrant des collabos et comment
vous pourrez lire ça madame et comment
vous pouvez employer ce mot parce que
vous êtes des collabos collabos de quoi
donner collabos 2e de la doxa
gouvernementale
nous a demandé de vous êtes quelqu'un de
dangereux
et en plus vous mentez matin mais c'est
la super